I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate Office Lovers podcast just for you. Each week we will dive deeper into the world of the office with exclusive interviews behind the scenes details and lots of BFF stories. We're the Office Lady 6.0. Howdy. Okay.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极的《办公室》爱好者的播客。每周，我们都会通过独家采访、幕后细节和大量的闺蜜故事，带你深入了解《办公室》的世界。我们是办公室辣妹6.0。大家好。好的。
I have been dying to ask you guys something. What? And by the time this episode comes out, this is going to feel like such. old news. But also, you know, sometimes when you're like a busy parent, you're running around and you're working and you're doing the things, it takes you longer to get to things that like the whole rest of the world is already done. Oh, is this a pop culture something? It is. It's pop culture. What is it? Late pop culture. Oh, that's my favorite. We have a podcast where we discuss pop culture, but like way after it's past, it's prime. Yes. Let's call it late to the party. I love it.
我一直急着想问你们一件事。什么事？等这集节目播出的时候，这感觉都会变成超级旧闻了。但同时，你也知道，有时当你是一个忙碌的父母，你到处奔波，忙着工作，忙着处理各种事情，你会花更多的时间才能接触到全世界其他人早就已经做过的事情。哦，这是关于流行文化的什么事吗？是的。是流行文化。是什么？过时的流行文化。哦，我最喜欢这个了。我们有一个播客节目，专门讨论流行文化，不过是在它过了全盛期好久之后。没错。我们叫它“迟到总比不到好”吧。我太喜欢了。
Right. Here's my late to the party. What? Have any of you watched Heated Rivalry? I saw the first episode. I haven't, I'm... You watched the whole first one now? Yes, same. Yeah.
对。我这就是“迟到总比不到好”。什么？你们有人看过《炽热对抗》吗？我看了第一集。我还没看，我……你现在把整整第一集看完了？是的，一样。对。
One episode. I just started because I'm late to the party. Yeah. Sam, Matt? No, I haven't. It's really good. Sam, it surprises me that you have not. I know.
就一集。我才刚开始看，因为我后知后觉。对。萨姆，马特？没有，我没看。这真的很好看。萨姆，你没看让我挺意外的。我知道。
I'm a very bad bisexual man. I'm very... I'm being reprimanded by multiple groups and multiple text threats. I will just say the two characters are both so interesting. Yeah. And they have their own sort of like story of how they got to this place and their family dynamics and the pressure on them as hockey players at that level. And just all of it is just really well done.
我是一个非常糟糕的双性恋男人。我非常……我正受到多方群体和多个短信威胁的斥责。我只想说，这两个角色都太有趣了。对。他们都有各自的故事，讲述他们是如何走到这一步的，他们的家庭动态，以及作为那个级别的曲棍球运动员所承受的压力。所有这些都制作得非常精良。
I'm watching it. You're watching it, Matt? Yeah, I want a little more hockey. That's my one complaint. Oh, I think a lot of dudes say that. Yeah. But I feel this way about any sort of sports adjacent. movie. I always want just like a little more sports. You want more sports. Just a little more.
我在看。你在看吗，马特？对，我想多看一点曲棍球。这是我唯一的抱怨。哦，我觉得很多男士都这么说。对。但我对任何这类稍微沾点运动边的电影都有这种感觉。我总是希望有……再多一点运动。你想要更多运动。再多一点点。
The hockey element is not on the ice hockey, but much more about the machine behind how hockey happens and how you get on a team and then like all the different. The business of the sport. Yeah. But I do feel like everything we're talking about right now is very much like focusing on the coffee mug in John Wick's kitchen. and it's kind of leaving the hot sexy time. Yeah. I mean, there's a lot of hot sexy time. It's mostly hot sexy time. Or the anticipation of hot sexy time are the buildup time. Yes.
曲棍球元素不是冰上曲棍球，而是更多关于曲棍球运作背后的机制，你是如何进入一支球队的，然后还有所有这些不同的……这项运动的商业运作。对。但我觉得我们现在谈论的一切，真的很像是在关注《疾速追杀》厨房里的那个马克杯，而有点忽略了火辣性感的激情戏。对。我的意思是，有很多火辣的激情戏。大部分都是火辣的激情戏。或者是火辣激情戏的期待感，也就是铺垫时间。是的。
This is very well described. There are some pretty incredible specimens, those guys. Oh, what do they say? They're snatched. No, that's old ladies that get facelifts. The guys can be snatched. Oh, they can? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
这形容得太贴切了。那些家伙简直是极品。哦，他们怎么说来着？他们身材绝佳（snatched）。不对，那是老太太做拉皮手术。男的也可以用“绝佳”。哦，可以吗？对，对，对。
Like six-pack, abs. Do you use the phrase? Do you just use the phrase perfectly correctly? Oh my gosh. Where's my confetti? I used to phrase correctly. Are you going to watch more episodes? I hear episode five is where it all happens.
比如六块腹肌。你用这个词吗？你用的这个词完全正确吗？哦天哪！我的彩纸呢？我把这个词用对了。你们还要看更多集吗？我听说第五集才是所有事情发生的地方。
Are you at episode five yet, Matt? I mean, a lot has happened before that. Well, I guess episode five is the one where people gasp. I've gasped a ton already. Okay, yeah, I'll keep going. So pretty much I only have an opportunity, like everyone's while to watch something by myself. Same. And the kids have been wanting to watch stranger things.
马特，你看到第五集了吗？我是说，之前已经发生了很多事了。好吧，我猜第五集是大家会倒吸一口凉气的那一集。我已经倒吸好几口气了。好吧，对，我会继续看的。所以基本上我只有偶尔有机会自己一个人看点东西。我也是。而且孩子们一直想看《怪奇物语》。
So we're doing that as a family. Yeah. So then I'll have to fine squeeze in my heated whiteberry somewhere else. Sam, please let us know if you start it. Oh, I will. Okay. Well, I loved that late to the party segment. And now it's time for our fan chit chat question of the week.
所以我们全家都在看那个。对。所以我得想办法把我的《炽热对抗》塞进其他时间里。萨姆，如果你开始看了，请让我们知道。哦，我会的。好吧。我很喜欢那个“迟到总比不到好”的环节。现在是本周的粉丝闲聊问答时间。
This is coming from Charissa D in Queen Creek, Arizona. Hi, Angela and Jenna. I was wondering if there is. a specific nostalgic smell that instantly puts you in a good mood. So, for example, I'm a native Arizona born and raised, and it doesn't rain very much here in the desert. But when it does, there is a very particular smell that comes with it. And the smell is from the creosote bush. and the rain kind of activates those oils that are in the bush and on the leaves and creates this very like strong desert rain smell.
这个问题来自亚利桑那州奎因克里克（Queen Creek）的查丽莎·D（Charissa D）。嗨，安吉拉和珍娜。我想知道是否有一种特定的怀旧气味，能瞬间让你们心情变好？例如，我在亚利桑那州土生土长，沙漠里不怎么下雨。但当它下雨时，会有一种非常独特的气味随之而来。这种气味来自油脂木（creosote）灌木。雨水会激活灌木丛和叶子中的那些精油，创造出一种非常强烈的沙漠雨水的气味。
And if you've ever been in Arizona during monsoon season or any other rainy day, you probably have smelled it. And some people really like it and some people don't. But for an Arizona native, it's very nostalgic. It's very comforting and it instantly lifts my mood. And I'm just happy when I smell that smell. And so I was wondering if you guys had something like that, maybe from your childhood or adulthood that is nostalgic to you
如果你曾在季风季节或任何其他雨天去过亚利桑那州，你可能闻到过它。有些人真的很喜欢它，有些人则不喜欢。但对于亚利桑那州的本地人来说，这非常具有怀旧感。它非常抚慰人心，能瞬间提升我的心情。当我闻到这种气味时，我就会很开心。所以我很想知道你们是否有过类似的东西，也许来自你们的童年或成年时期，对你们来说具有怀旧感，
and immediately puts you in a really good mood. I loved this question. This is one I picked. I loved learning about this bush that makes the smell in Arizona. I just found this so relatable because I think smells really do transport you. So I had a few. Can I just jump right in?
并且能立刻让你们的心情变得非常好。我太喜欢这个问题了。这是我挑的一个。我很高兴能了解到这种在亚利桑那州散发气味的灌木。我发现这太有共鸣了，因为我认为气味真的能带你穿越时空。所以我有一些。我可以马上说吗？
Yes, please. So you guys, the thing that takes me back to childhood, not only memories from my own, but also memories of raising Isabel when she was little, is the smell of Play-Doh. Like, you know that smell? Yeah. You open up a fresh can of Play-Doh. it has such a distinct smell. And it just always makes me think of when she was little.
好的，请说。所以你们知道，能把我带回童年的东西，不仅有我自己的回忆，还有把伊莎贝尔拉扯大的回忆，那就是培乐多（Play-Doh）橡皮泥的味道。就像，你知道那种味道吗？对。你打开一罐新鲜的培乐多，它有一种非常独特的味道。它总是让我想起她小的时候。
And it was such a precious time. We would just make all kinds of stuff with Play-Doh. Were you ever tempted to take a bite you or her? Yes, both of us. It's got that little tempting thing to it. Yeah. And then you know you can make your own Play-Doh, which I did as well. So there's that smell.
那是多么珍贵的一段时光。我们以前用培乐多做各种各样的东西。你或者她有没有曾经想咬一口的冲动？是的，我们俩都有。它有一种小小的诱惑力。对。然后你知道你可以自己做培乐多，我也做过。所以有那种味道。
But much like Teresa, there is a smell that immediately makes me think of our family farm. and it's also a plant. It's called Texas Sage, and it's a type of plant. And when I go to the farm, and Jenna, you've got to go to the farm with me. I really want that to happen. We've talked about this as a goal that you're going to come to the farm, and I'm going to go to St. Louis with you. Yes.
但就像特蕾莎一样，有一种气味立刻让我想起我们的家庭农场，它也是一种植物。它叫德州鼠尾草（Texas Sage），是一种植物。当我回农场的时候，珍娜，你一定要跟我一起去农场。我真的很想实现这个愿望。我们把这当成一个目标，你要来农场，我要跟你去圣路易斯。是的。
But I used to ride in the back of the pickup truck on the farm, because, you know, there was no major road. You're just on this little dirt road on the farm, and my grandparents would let us kids all ride in the back of the truck. and that smell as you drive through the pasture of that sagebrush is so distinct. And I would just breathe it in. And there's just nothing for miles. It felt like I was taking all this fresh air and goodness into my body.
但我以前经常坐在农场的皮卡车后斗里，因为，你知道的，那里没有主干道。你只是在农场里那条小土路上，我祖父母会让我们这群小孩都坐在卡车后斗里。当你开车穿过长满鼠尾草的牧场时，那种气味是如此独特。我就会深深地吸一口气。方圆几英里什么都没有。感觉我把所有的清新空气和美好都吸进身体里了。
I love that. Yeah. What about you? I had nothing come to mind. What? You know smells from growing up? I clearly need to smell more. I just thought of who doesn't love fresh-baked cookies or who doesn't love the smell of their mom's special dinner on Christmas or, you know, like I...
我太喜欢了。对。你呢？我脑子里什么也没想。什么？你不知道成长过程中的气味吗？我显然需要闻更多东西。我刚想到，谁能不爱刚出炉的饼干，谁能不爱妈妈在圣诞节做的特色晚餐的味道，或者，你知道的，就像我……
You sort of had some general thoughts. Yeah, but I really tried to think about like a specific smell. I mean, things that came to mind were Old Spice after shave. That's what my dad wore when I was a little kid. My grandpa wore it. So that brings up great memories. But weirdly, like I thought of smells like the mixture of oil and gasoline that you smell when my dad would gas up the boat. Yes, that's what we're talking about.
你大概有一些总体的想法。对，但我真的很努力去想一种特定的气味。我的意思是，脑子里浮现的东西有Old Spice须后水。那是当我还是个小孩子时我爸爸用的。我爷爷也用过。所以这勾起了美好的回忆。但奇怪的是，我想到了油和汽油混合的气味，当你爸爸给船加满油时能闻到那种味道。对，这才是我们在讨论的。
Yes. You know? You're doing it. Am I? You're doing it in real time. You're like attaching a smell to a memory. Yeah. But every time I smell gas, I don't think of being.
对。你知道吗？你正在经历这个过程。是吗？你正在实时经历。你就像是在把气味和记忆联系起来。对。但每次我闻到汽油味，我并不觉得是在。
on the lake as a kid. But there are smells, I guess. But I feel like I need to tune into the aromas of my life. Sure. I'm going to. Be more attention to the smells around you. Well, you know, they talk about if you are having a hard time being present, touch and smell are two of the things that can, you know, in some meditations I've done,
小时候在湖上。但我想确实有些气味。不过我觉得我需要调动我生活中的各种香气。当然。我会的。多关注你周围的气味。好吧，你知道，人们常说如果你很难活在当下，触觉和嗅觉是两件可以，你知道的，在我做过的一些冥想中，
they're like, what do you smell? Mm-hmm. Okay. What do you feel right now? All right, Sam. All right. And this answer, I want to keep in mind, you guys, you asked me this question. Oh, my gosh.
他们会问，你闻到了什么？嗯哼。好吧，你现在感觉到了什么？好吧，萨姆。好吧。对于这个答案，我希望你们记住，你们问了我这个问题。哦，天哪。
What are we in for? There is a tree from my childhood and growing up in North Carolina, and outside of North Carolina called the Calorie pear tree. And it smells like cum. It smells like. The cum tree. Yes. Thank you.
我们这是要听什么？我童年和在北卡罗来纳州长大的时候，有一种树，在北卡罗来纳州以外的地方叫豆梨树（Calorie pear tree）。它闻起来像精液。它闻起来像。精液树。是的。谢谢。
How did you know instantly what you was talking about? Thank you for making me not seem crazy. Sam, we have one in our neighborhood. Okay. We have a cum tree. It's a, the technical term, it's a calorie pear tree. They're an invasive species. They're banned in a couple states, but yeah, they smell like cum.
你怎么能瞬间就知道你在说什么？谢谢你让我看起来不像是疯了。萨姆，我们社区里就有一棵。好吧。我们有一棵精液树。它是，用专业术语来说，它是一棵豆梨树。它们是一种外来入侵物种。它们在好几个州都被禁止种植了，但确实，它们闻起来像精液。
It's a really. A really overpowering smell. It's the coconut water of aromas. Yes, yes, it is. Basically. Wow. I've never heard of this tree. Yes.
这真的是。一种气味非常浓烈的树。它是香气中的椰子水。是的，是的，就是这样。基本上。哇。我从来没听说过这种树。是的。
You'll know it. You will know it. You will know it. There's a certain time of year that when we walk in our neighborhood, you're like, there it is. Yep. Yeah. How do we have that?
你会认出来的。你绝对会认出来的。你肯定会认出来的。一年中的某个特定时间，当我们走在社区里时，你会觉得：看，就是那个。没错。对。我们怎么会有那种东西？
I don't know. Someone planted it illegally, apparently. I guess. I know 100% what you're talking about. So that tree makes you think of your childhood. Yes, makes me think of North Carolina. Yeah. Well, I'll let you know when it's blooming in my neighborhood and you can come by and
我不知道。显然是有人非法种植的。我猜是吧。我百分之百知道你在说什么。所以那棵树让你想起你的童年。是的，让我想起北卡罗来纳州。好吧，等它在我社区里开花的时候我会告诉你，你可以顺道过来。
want to have a smell. Think of home. Matt. Yeah, I thought my. I thought my. I thought mine was risque. I was going to say Clinique Happy because my first ever girlfriend wore Clinique Happy. And it's so powerful.
想闻一闻。想想家。马特。对，我还以为我的。我还以为我的。我还以为我的比较带风险呢。我本来想说Clinique Happy（倩碧快乐）香水，因为我的初恋女友用的是Clinique Happy。而且它太浓烈了。
Like I some, I don't know, mom at some school event was wearing Clinique Happy at a thing recently. And I was like, I'm sorry, are you wearing Clinique Happy? And it really took me right back there. It really rattled you. You're like, oh, wait. I was like, I need to leave. I'm going to pass out. Yeah, that takes me back to early high school.
比如我，我不知道，最近在某个学校活动上，某个妈妈喷了Clinique Happy香水，然后我就想，不好意思，你喷的是Clinique Happy吗？它真的把我直接带回了那个时候。它真的把你吓得不轻。你当时就像，哦，等等。我当时就想，我得离开这里。我要晕倒了。对，那把我带回了高中早期。
Yeah. Oh, my gosh. That's amazing. All right. Well, Terissa, thank you so much for that question. I loved it. Why don't we take a break? And when we come back, we're going to be breaking down episode eight of the paper, church and state. All right, this is episode eight of season one of the paper, written by Ben Philippe and directed by Matt Sown. Yay! And we reached out to Matt Sown. You guys know listening that Matt was our camera operator on the office. He also directed many episodes. and he sent us in some behind the scenes little tidbits that we'll share throughout this episode.
对。哦，天哪。太惊人了。好吧。嗯，特瑞莎，非常感谢你提出那个问题。我很喜欢。我们为什么不休息一下呢？当我们回来时，我们将剖析《报社》第八集，《教会与国家》。好的，这是《报社》第一季的第八集，由本·菲利普（Ben Philippe）编剧，马特·索恩（Matt Sown）导演。耶！我们联系了马特·索恩。收听节目的各位都知道，马特曾是我们《办公室》的摄影师。他还执导过许多集。他给我们发了一些幕后的有趣小花絮，我们将在本集中分享。
Let me hit you with a summary. Ned's past as a high-pressure toilet paper salesman comes in handy when mayor uncovers a story that pits the truth teller against its corporate owner. Meanwhile, as Morelda becomes a stage mom to help her son book a commercial. That was so cringy. We'll get to it. We have a cold open where Ned is sharing that he enjoys arriving early to work to review stories and catch up on emails. And as he's going through sort of like this storage area where there's all these files of papers, he discovers mayor has been sleeping at the office.
让我用一个总结来轰炸你们。内德作为高压卫生纸推销员的过去派上了用场，当时市长揭露了一个让真理捍卫者与公司老板对立的故事。与此同时，莫雷尔达成了一位虎妈，帮她儿子接拍商业广告。那真是太让人脚趾抠地了。我们待会儿会说到。有一个冷开场，内德分享说他喜欢早到公司来审阅稿件和处理邮件。当他穿过那个堆满了各种纸质档案的储藏区时，他发现梅尔一直睡在办公室里。
Yeah, there's an issue with her plumbing. She hasn't been able to bathe. And Ned notices she really smells. My favorite line in this entire episode and I need to text Chelsea. about it is mayor's response to Ned when Ned says, God, what's that smell? And Mayor goes, I'm doing what I can. She's like so defeated. She's like, she doesn't have anywhere to bathe. Well, Ned's going to offer to let her go over to his place and take a shower, but please don't use the nice shampoo. Ned? I mean, I stand with Ned. What? Well, I mean, if you've got a really
对，她的水管出了问题。她一直没法洗澡。内德注意到她身上有一股很难闻的味道。整集中我最喜欢的一句台词，我得给切尔西发个短信讨论一下，那就是内德说“天哪，什么味儿啊”时，梅尔对内德的回答。梅尔说：“我已经尽力了。”她显得太沮丧了。她就像是，她没地方洗澡。好吧，内德主动提出让她去他那里洗个澡，但是请不要用那个昂贵的洗发水。内德？我的意思是，我站在内德这边。什么？好吧，我的意思是，如果你有一瓶真的很贵重的洗发水，你知道的，也许……留着给自己用吧。我的意思是，也许你不想经常分享它，但只洗一次澡的话。好吧。她就去那儿一次。好吧。就让她用一下那个洗发水吧。我觉得，我不知道。好吧，我不知道你们有没有注意到，梅尔穿着一件T恤，有点像复古风的T恤，上面有个类似牛仔的图案。上面写着斯特吉尔·辛普森（Sturgis Simpson）。我不知道那是个真人还是我心想，也许是个企业。我不知道。是个乐队吗？
expensive shampoo, you know, maybe like save that for yourself. I mean, maybe you don't want to share it on a regular basis, but like a single shower. Okay. She's going over there one time. Okay. Let her just use the shampoo. I think, I don't know. Well, I don't know if you notice, but Merritt is wearing a t-shirt, sort of like a vintage looking tea with a kind of a cowboy on it. And it says Sturgle Simpson. And I didn't know. if that was a real person or I'm like, maybe it's a business. I don't know. Is it a band?
是个伙计。他是歌手吗？是的，他太棒了。哦。我问过切尔西这件事，她说在跟服装设计师凯瑟琳（Kathleen）最初的对话中，他们作为角色讨论的一部分，稍微聊了一下梅尔的音乐品味。但最终，这件T恤是凯瑟琳的主意。切尔西说她很喜欢，因为她是他的超级粉丝。
It's a guy. Is he a singer? Yes, and he's so good. Oh. I asked Chelsea about it and she said early in her conversations with Kathleen, the costume designer, they talked a little bit about Mayer's musical tastes as part of her character discussions. But ultimately, this shirt was Kathleen's idea. And Chelsea says she loves it because she's a big fan.
所以我当时就想，我得查查这个人。我查了一下。他太厉害了。再次说到“迟到总比不到好”。我现在对她着迷了。我一直在听他的歌。对，我也要听。他让我想起老派乡村音乐，比如威隆·詹宁斯（Waylon Jennings），就是那种范儿。人们就是把他和那些人作比较。对。好吧，现在我们要进入这一集了。每个人都在调查这个巨大的堵塞物。他们真的就像街头的记者。他们拿着记事本和铅笔，妮可也在，梅尔也在，奥斯卡和巴里也在。有一辆巨大的卡车，试图疏通下水道，对吧？对，有，是的，所有这些城市车辆都在试图弄清楚发生了什么。
So I'm like, I got to look this guy up. up. I looked him up. He's amazing. Talk about late to the party again. I'm obsessed now. I'm listening to him all the time. Yeah, I'm going to as well. He reminds me of like old country, like Whaling Jennings, like that whole vibe. That's who he gets compared to. Yeah. Well, now we're going to get into the episode. Everyone is out investigating this giant clogged. They're literally like man on the street. They've got their notepads and their pencils and Nicole's there and Maher's there and Oscar and Barry. there's a huge truck, like trying to unclog the sewer, right? Yeah, there's like, yeah, all these city vehicles trying to figure out what's going on.
到底怎么了？原来梅尔的整个社区都受到了这个巨大堵塞物的影响。奥斯卡有一个采访镜头，他说：“内德真的很兴奋。这将是一个大新闻。”巴里有点生气，因为这也会影响到他女朋友的公寓。现在她，我猜，跟他住在一起了，他很不喜欢这样。对。我想指出的是，在奥斯卡说话的整个过程中，
What's going on? It turns out Mayer's entire neighborhood has been affected by this giant clog. And Oscar has a talking head where he says, Ned's really excited. This is going to be a big story. Barry is kind of ticked off because this is also affecting his girlfriend's apartment. And now she, I guess, is bunking with him and he doesn't like that. Yeah. I want to point out this entire time that Oscar is talking.
从1分58秒到2分27秒，他手里一直拿着一个巨大的墨西哥卷饼。谁能在下水道堵塞物旁边吃东西？我是说，谁会想吃？这就是我的意思。我知道。现在，他一口都没咬。这只是他全程都得拿着的道具。对，但我觉得他一说完话，就会大口享用这个看起来像个巨大早餐卷饼的东西。嗯哼。我发现自己一直在等他咬上一口那个卷饼。结果并没有。至少在播出的版本里没有。没有。我们应该提醒大家，我们看的是播出的版本，因为这是NBC正在播放、每个人都能看到的版本。是的，是免费的。好吧，埃斯梅拉达现在要来上班了，电梯间旁边的走廊里坐着长长的一队人。看起来像妈妈带着孩子，因为他们在为Kid Mitz商业广告进行试镜。我能告诉你们我最喜欢的埃斯梅拉达的台词吗？
from one minute 58 seconds to two minutes and 27 seconds, he's holding a huge burrito. Who can eat next to a sewer clog? I mean, who wants to? That's what I mean. I know. Now, he never takes a bite of it. It's just a prop he has to hold the whole entire time. Yeah, but I feel like as soon as he's done talking, he's going to lay into this what looks
她说：“为什么到处都是小屁孩和他们的老妈？这是在西南航空（Southwest）登机C组吗？”她为什么要暗讽西南航空？我不知道很明显她不坐西南航空。我对西南航空的C组登机很熟悉。我对A组很熟悉，因为乔希买了优先登机（Early Bird）。对，我们尽量这么做。
like a giant breakfast burrito. Mm-hmm. I just found myself just waiting for him to take a bite of this. the burrito. It doesn't happen. At least not in the broadcast version. No. And we should remind people, we're watching the broadcast version because it's the one that's running on NBC that's accessible to everyone. Yes, it's free. Yes. Well, Esmeralda is now going to arrive to work and there's like this long line of people sitting in the hallway by the elevator banks. It looks like moms with their kids because they're holding auditions for the Kid Mitz commercial. Can I tell you my favorite Esmeralda line?
你并不总能买到。好吧，你得手快。好吧，现在西南航空有指定座位了。我知道。我们对此有何感想？我不知道，我……我刚给自己订了一张西南航空的机票，而且我选到了一个靠过道的座位，
She says, why are their children and their mothers everywhere? Is Group C boarding on a Southwest flight? Why is she going to throw shade at Southwest? I don't know. She doesn't fly Southwest, clearly. I'm familiar with Group C boarding on a Southwest flight. I'm familiar with Group A because Josh does Early Bird. Yeah, we try to do that.
我当时兴奋得不得了。我太喜欢了。这太棒了。你知道吗？能够提前挑选？你喜欢吗？喜欢。对。
You don't always get it. Well, you got to be quick. Well, now Southwest has assigned seats. I know. How do we feel about it? I don't, I... I just booked myself on a Southwest flight, and I was able to pick an aisle seat,
我讨厌那种争抢座位的混乱。我喜欢选座位。争抢座位让我感到压力山大。就像在电影院里努力确保你和你的朋友能买到好座位一样。对。然后会有人给你翻白眼，因为也许你得把连帽衫放在座位上，
and I got, like, super excited about it. I love that. That's incredible. You know what? Being able to pick ahead of time? You like it? Yes. Yeah.
因为你的朋友没跟你在同一组登机。完全正确。对。没有人能永远满意。我不需要那种压力。好吧，我们支持这个规定，我猜。好吧，回到这一集。
I hate the free-for-all. I like picking my seat. The free-for-all stresses me out. It's like trying to make sure you and your friends get good seats at the movies. Yeah. And then someone's going to give you the starky side eye because maybe you have to put your hoodie on a seat
肯有一个采访镜头，从中我们了解到Softys公司的一款名为man mitts的产品取得了惊人的成功。它们看起来有点像你用来擦屁股的卫生纸手套。对。他在采访镜头里戴着它们，它们就像是白手套。对。对。这个想法是，你把这些东西戴在手上，然后在你上完大号后擦屁股。没错。
because your friend isn't boarding in your group. Exactly. Yeah. No one's ever satisfied. I don't need that stress. Yeah. We're for it, I guess. Okay, back to this episode.
你知道这其实是个真东西，而且它们被称为shittins吗？不知道。对。它们在亚马逊上有售，是专为父母在帮孩子擦屁股时使用的。特别是如果你有一个年幼的孩子，他们拉得很严重（big blowout）时，你可以用一个shittin。我想知道这个名字的创意推介会议是怎么开的。我不知道。它让人过目难忘。Shittins。
Ken has this talking head where we learn that Softys has had this amazing success with a product called man mitts. They kind of look like toilet paper gloves you use to wipe your butt. Yeah. He's wearing them in the talking head and they're like white gloves. Yeah. Yeah. The idea is that you put these things on your hands and then you wipe after you go number two. Right.
它们每个大约要一美元。它们能冲进马桶吗？不能。它们被标为一次性用品，但既不可生物降解，也不能冲入马桶。所以它们将永远存在。好吧，难道从技术上讲，所有东西都是一次性的吗？是的，因为这意味着它是单次使用的，你用完就扔了。没错。
Did you know this is a real thing and that they're called shittins? No. Yeah. They're available on Amazon and they were designed for parents to use while wiping their kids' butts. Like particularly if you have like a young child and they have like a big blowout, you can use a shittin. I want to know the like pitch meeting for the title of the name. I don't know. It's memorable. Shittins.
但我的意思是，字面意思上，任何东西都可以是一次性的，只要我把它处理掉。比如，我可以在我孩子的屁股上用一条毛巾，然后把它扔掉。对。于是它就变成了一次性用品。我是说，我的钱包。比方说我不再想要我的钱包了。一次性。一次性。
They cost about a dollar per shittin. Are they flushable? No. They are labeled as disposable but not biodegradable or flushable. So they're going to live forever. Well, isn't everything technically disposable? Yes, because that means it's single use and you throw it away. Right.
完全正确。所以，但这，这是Shittins网站上的一个巨大卖点，就是它们是一次性的。但我只是想说。那真是一些营销小把戏。好吧，我问过格雷格（Greg），Shittins是不是激发了man mitts或kidmits的灵感。他说没有，他从来没听说过shittins。他说它们的灵感来自餐饮服务手套。
But I mean, literally anything can be disposable if I just dispose of it. Like, I could use a washcloth on my kid's butt and then just throw it away. Yeah. And so becomes disposable. I mean, my purse. Let's say I don't want my purse anymore. Disposable. Disposable.
这就是他在写这一集时对它们的描述。所以我只是觉得很有趣，格雷格竟然独立想出了一款擦大便的手套。我一点也不觉得奇怪。他可能在另一个平行世界里会成为某种发明家。对。他总是对这类事情有各种想法。确实如此。肯分享说，他和内德就如何最好地宣传man mitts有过几次激烈的争论。我们有一个闪回到前一天的镜头。我太喜欢这段对话了。内德说，他对肯非常生气。他情绪激昂。他说：“我才不会把你的擦屁股手套叫作个人卫生的青霉素呢。”是的，所以他们争来争去，肯说了一些话，安吉拉，大意是，哦，就因为
Exactly. So, but this is, it's a big selling point on the Shitton's website is that they are disposable. But I just wanted to say. That is like some marketing trickery. Well, I asked Greg, if Shitton's, inspired the man mitts or the kidmits. And he said no, he had never heard of shittens. He said they were inspired by food service gloves.
公司总部拥有这个项目，你就不打算为它写一篇赞美的评论了吗？内德说：“你说得对。我们必须要有教会与国家的分离（政教分离）。我们必须把这两个实体分开。”是的，这以后可能会反过来咬他们一口。我们待会儿会说到。所以现在我们来到街上，梅尔和妮可正在看着
And that's how he described them when they were writing this episode. So I just think it's interesting that Greg independently thought of a poop wiping glove. I'm not surprised by it. He like probably in another life would have been like some kind of inventor. Yeah. He always has ideas about things like that. It's true. Ken shares that him and Ned have had a few heated debates about how to best get the word out about the mann mitts. We have a flashback to the day before. And I love this dialogue. Ned says, he's really ticked off at Ken. He's fired up. He says, I'm not calling your ass wiping glove the penicillin of personal hygiene. Yeah, so they go back and forth and Ken says something, Angela, about like, oh, just because
这个极其恶心、巨大无比的垃圾团块从下水道里被拉出来。妮可说：“这在你看来像什么？”咚，咚，咚。猜猜那是什么？好吧，他们回办公室拍了照片。
the corporate office owns this item, you're not going to write about a glowing review of it. And Ned's like, you're correct. We have to have a separation of church and state. We have to separate these two entities. Yeah, that might come back to bite them in the butt later. we'll get to it. So now we're out on the street and Mary and Nicole are watching
他们把照片拿给内德看。原来是man mitts。对，成千上万个。你知道，这让我去谷歌了一下。我希望大家最近没有吃东西，但我确实深入研究了历史上最大的下水道堵塞物。它被称为白教堂胖山（Whitechapel Fatburg），是2017年在伦敦东部白教堂下方的下水道里发现的。那是什么？好吧，它是烹饪油脂、湿纸巾和其他东西的混合物。
this really disgusting giant, massive clump of stuff getting pulled out of the sewer. And Nicole says, what does that look like to you? Dun, dun, dun. Guess what it is? Well, they took pictures back in the office.
其他卫生用品。哦，天哪。它有250米长，大约相当于两个半美式足球场。哦。它重达130吨，或者说大约相当于11辆双层巴士。哦，天哪。Fatburg（胖山）这个词最初是用来形容那些曾经被冲上英国海滩的岩石状烹饪油脂团块的，
They're showing them to Ned. And it's the man mitts. Yeah, thousands of them. You know, this got me Googling. I hope no one has eaten recently, but I did deep dive the biggest sewer clog in history. And it's called the Whitechapel Fatburg, and it was found in a sewer below Whitechapel in East London in 2017. What was it? Well, it was a combination of cooking fat, wet wipes, and other.
因为人们会把烹饪油脂倒进下水道。但现在它被下水道工人用来形容由于人们把油脂倒进下水道而导致的下水道堵塞，然后它会与其他不易降解的东西凝结在一起。伦敦已经发生过很多次这种情况，但这个白教堂胖山是最大的。
other sanitary products. Oh, God. It was 250 meters long, which is about two and a half American football fields. Oh. And it weighed 130 tons or about the same as 11 double-decker buses. Oh, my gosh. The term Fatberg was first used to describe the rock-like lumps of cooking fat that used to wash up on British beaches
清理它花了两个月、零七天，每周无休。天哪。你可能在问自己，我能去看看那个胖山吗？没，但是好吧。你可以的。我当时就在想。它被伦敦博物馆保存了下来，并且正在展出。
because people would pour their cooking fat down the drain. But now it's been adopted by sewer workers to describe sewer clogs caused by people pouring their grease down the drain and then it's sort of like coagulating with other things that aren't degrading quickly. London has had a lot of them, but this Whitechapel-Fatburg was the biggest.
等等，那是他们永久收藏的一部分吗？大约是11。其中的一部分。好吧。不是整个。我当时想，那就像是个什么地方的巨石阵。而且，它随着时间发生了变化。很好。
It took two months, seven days, a week to clear it. Jeez. And you might be asking yourself, can I see the Fatberg? Wasn't, but okay. You can. I was. It's been preserved by the London Museum and it's on display.
嗯哼。所以当他们刚收到它的一部分时，因为他们问过，我们能要一块吗？他们一直在想怎么把它展出来，因为一开始它里面充满了细菌和有毒气体。所以他们不得不把它拿出去通通风，把它烘干。他们当时心想，好吧，我想现在应该没问题了。于是他们把它放在玻璃下面。但我想它里面还是有一些水分，因为它开始出汗了。哦，天哪。
Wait, that's part of their permanent collection. It's like 11. A section of it. Okay. Not the whole thing. I was like, that's like a monolith somewhere. Also, it has changed over time. Good.
别说出汗。它开始在玻璃下面出汗。然后它的颜色开始改变，从深棕色变成浅灰色，再变成深米色。它现在是什么样子的？哦，不，它还好吗？它现在是深米色的。还有，上面长了霉菌。然后到了一定时候，苍蝇开始从里面自然孵化出来。
Mm-hmm. So when they first received a piece of it, because they asked, can we have a piece of it? They were trying to figure out how to display it because at first it was like full of bacteria and toxic gases. So they had to like air it out, dry it out. And they kind of thought like, okay, I think it's good now. So they put it under glass. But I guess it still had some moisture in it because it started to sweat. Oh, God.
好吧，是的。他们说苍蝇现在已经没了。现在胖山正在慢慢缩小。体积在变小。它是在缺氧吗？我的孩子们能看到它吗？伙计们，我不知道。它缩小的速度有多快？
Don't say sweat. It started to sweat under the glass. And then it started changing colors from like dark brown to pale gray to dark beige. What is it now? Oh, no, is it okay? It's dark beige now. Also, mold grew on it. And then at a certain point, flies started spontaneously hatching out of it.
我没说。比冰盖还快吗？上面没说。哦，不。我觉得这东西会比我们所有人都活得久。我想我们都得在它消失之前立刻去看看。在它消失之前。顺便说一句，美国也有过一些胖山。
Well, yeah. They said the flies are gone now. And now the Fatberg is slowly shrinking. That's getting smaller. Is it running out of oxygen? Will my children be able to see it? You guys, I don't know. How fast is it shrinking?
向2018年密歇根州克林顿镇和2017年马里兰州巴尔的摩致敬。密歇根那个有100英尺长。11英尺宽，6英尺高，大约是伦敦那个的八分之一。所以美国。而且这也是最近的事。这是一个我们至今仍未解决的问题。这是一个最近才出现的问题。天哪。
I didn't say. Faster than the ice cabs? It didn't say. Oh, no. I feel like this is going to outlive all of us. I think we all need to see it immediately before it's gone. Before it's gone. Incidentally, the United States have had some fatburgs as well.
呃。我不知道为什么，但这让我想起你们俩都熟悉的戴夫·马修斯乐队（Dave Matthews Band）2004年芝加哥河事件。对。没有。他们是故意的吗？没有，好吧。传闻是这样的，2004年8月8日，
Shout out to Clinton Township, Michigan in 2018 and Baltimore, Maryland in 2017. The Michigan one was 100 feet long. 11 feet wide and 6 feet tall, roughly an eighth of the size of the London one. So America. And this is recent, too. This is a problem we still haven't solved. It's a recent problem. Jeez.
乐队的巡演大巴将大约800磅的人类排泄物从其黑水箱中通过芝加哥的肯齐街桥（Kenzie Street Bridge）倾倒到下方的一艘观光船上。那艘船刚好从下面开过。太诡异了。他们是故意的。那个家伙拉了杆子。我听过一个关于它的完整播客。真的很好。为什么不想往船上拉屎呢？
Ugh. I don't know why, but that makes me think of you guys are both familiar with the Dave Matthews Band 2004 Chicago River incident. Yeah. No. Did they do that on purpose? No, okay. So the legend goes on August 8, 2004,
她不想往船上拉屎。与其把大巴开去接上那个处理设施，那家伙心想：我就在过桥时按个按钮吧。他知道他们是在把废物倒进河里。他不知道那会倒在一船人身上。完全正确。哦，天哪。对。
The band tour bus dumped approximately 800 pounds of human waste from its blackwater tank through a Kenzie Street Bridge in Chicago onto a sightseeing boat below. That was going under. That's so weird. They did it on purpose. The guy pulled the lever. I listened to a whole podcast on it. It's really good. Why didn't want to like shit on the boat?
那座桥叫什么名字？肯齐街桥（Kinsey Street Bridge）。Kinsey。他们是怎么拼的？K-I-N-Z-I-E。好吧。你知道那个播客节目《警报器》（The Alarmist）吗？对。
She didn't want to shit on the boat. It was like rather than go hook the bus up to the thing. He was like, I'll just hit the button as we're going over the bridge. He knew they were dumping in the river. He didn't know it would go onto a boat of people. Exactly. Oh, my God. Yeah.
他们做了一整集关于这个的节目。很棒。你知道，他们的工作就是找出谁该承担责任。是的。为了历史上的不同事件。所以他们想讨论谁该为那件事负责。好吧，太好了。我听过。
What was the name of the bridge? The Kinsey Street Bridge. Kinsey. How do they spell it? K-I-N-Z-I-E. Okay. You know that podcast, The Alarmist? Yeah.
我怪那个按按钮的人。好吧，埃斯梅拉达现在基本上要变成《亲爱的妈咪》（Mommie Dearest）里的那种人了。这让我觉得太脚趾抠地了。她把她的儿子马特奥（Mateo）从学校里硬拽了出来。他说：“我正在参加数学考试。”她却说：“那又怎样？加法，减法。你长大后想当什么？花匠吗？”
They did a whole episode on it. It's great. You know, their job is to figure out who's to blame. Yes. for different things in history. So they wanted to discuss who was to blame for that. Okay, good. I listened to it.
对，她就像拽着他穿过街道一样把他硬拽走，好快点带他去为这个商业广告试镜。与此同时，内德开始对他们的胖山进行调查。他想知道是谁知道这些湿纸巾其实不能冲进马桶。他们是什么时候知道的？他们能信任谁？他要写一篇关于这个的报道。
I blame the guy who pressed the button. Well, Esmeralda is now going to become basically a version of Mommy Dearest. It's like so cringy to me. She yanks her kid, Mateo, out of school. He's like, I was taking a math test. And she's like, so what? Addition, subtraction. What do you want to be when you grow up a florist?
对。梅尔和他是同谋。她要去找金博（Kimbo）套取情报。哦，我太喜欢这个场景了。她试图向她调情。我截了个片段。我觉得我们应该听听。我们听听看。
Yeah. And she's like yanking him through the street. to take him quickly to audition for this commercial. Meanwhile, Ned is starting his investigation on their Fatberg. He wants to know who knew that these wipes really were not flushable. When did they know it? Who can they trust? He's going to write a story about it.
你好啊？嘿。我们能谈点事吗？女孩对女孩。当然啦，梅尔宝贝，女孩对女孩。这辫子真漂亮。是谁的生日吗？我是说，每周三都有人过生日。
Yeah. Mare's in cahoots with him. She's going to go try to get Intel from Kimbo. Oh, I loved this scene. She's trying to flirt with her. I pulled a clip. I think we should hear it. Let's hear it.
其中一个是你的，金发妞。关于那个man mitts。你们最近一直在卖很多那种好东西，对吧？对。好吧，我的问题是：你们有没有收到任何投诉，说它们其实不能冲进马桶？从我的桌子上滚开。
How you doing? Hey. Can we talk about something? I'm a girl to girl. Of course, Mary Bear, girl on girl. That's gorgeous braid. Is somebody's birthday? I mean, every Wednesday someone's birthday.
那是本周我最欣赏的场景。哦，是吗？还记得我说过我要选我最喜欢的吗？这就是我最喜欢的。我喜欢这两个女人在一起。我喜欢“每周三都有人过生日”这句台词。这台词太棒了。太棒了。
One's yours, Blondie. So the man met. You guys have been moving a lot of those bad boys lately, huh? Yeah. Okay, here's my question. Have you guys gotten any complaints that they're not actually flushable? get off my desk.
我喜欢他们的化学反应。她俩都非常搞笑。我喜欢那个辫子。那不是她的头发。所以我就觉得，她只是有时选择戴那种附加的。马尾辫假发片之类的东西。看起来就像那种，如果你有个女儿，她正处于《冰雪奇缘》的阶段，她想要一条长长的艾莎（Elsa）辫子，一直垂下来并搭在肩膀上。
That's my chef's kiss scene of the week. Oh, yeah? Remember I said I was going to say my favorite? This is my favorite. I like these two women together. I love the line every Wednesday is someone's birthday. That's a great line. It's great.
把它夹在头发后面。这让我想起了我早期的白色大象换物派对（Yankee swap party），你赢得了假发。哦，对。我赢了其中一个。它有一匹马尾巴那么长。真的有。我有一张你的照片。那天晚上你在派对上把它戴上了，你戴着它。
I like their dynamic. They're both really funny. I loved the braid. It's not her hair. So I'm like, she just sometimes elects to wear those attached. Ponytail braid things. It looks like the thing that like if you have a daughter and she's in her frozen stage and she wants to have the long Elsa braid that comes down and goes over her shoulder.
剩下的时间都在戴着。我有一张照片，你把那个巨大的马尾辫甩在肩上。那个东西后来怎么处理了？我不知道。你把它带回家了。我带了。我在家里没找到。你知道吗？那个可能是一次性的。哦，我觉得那是一次性的。很可能。那天晚上很多人，如果他们不喜欢他们得到的礼物，就会把它藏在我家里。我会在几个月甚至几年后发现一些东西。好吧，你知道的，我们现在接管了白色大象换物圣诞派对的传统。是的，你们是和孩子们一起玩。我那时是和吵闹的成年人。
Clip it to the back of her hair. It reminded me of one of my early Yankee swap parties and you won the fake hair. Oh yeah. I won one of those. It was like as long as a horse's tail. It really was. I have a picture of you. You attached it that night at the party you wore it for the.
对，但我们每年家里也会留下很多东西。好吧，希望不是故意的。好吧，有一年，奥斯卡的女儿赢得了一个亮片抱枕。就像那种一面是红色的，但如果你把亮片往上一抹，就会变成别的东西的抱枕。那上面只是留下了尼古拉斯·凯奇（Nicholas Cage）的照片，我们现在每年圣诞节都会把它拿出来，他们觉得这真的很好笑。那其实真的是一个很棒的白色大象换物礼物。我同意。
the rest of the night. I have a picture of you sort of like over the shoulder with your giant horse ponytail. Whatever happened to that? I don't know. You took it home. I did. I didn't find it at my house. You know what? That might have been disposable. Oh, I think it was disposable. It might have been. A lot of people that night, if they didn't like the gift they got, they hid it around my house. And I found it like months and months later, I would find things. Well, you know, we've taken over the Yankee Swap Christmas party tradition now. Yes, you do it with kids. Mine was like rowdy adults.
尼古拉斯·凯奇的亮片抱枕，根据方向的不同，图案也会变。对。这太绝了。好吧。内德把妮可、德里克、亚当和阿德洛拉（Adelola）叫进他的办公室。他需要整个团队来做这个报道。特拉维斯（Travis）试图进来加入他们，但内德说：“我很抱歉。我需要你回避，因为这篇报道会牵连到Softys公司，
Yeah, but we get a lot of things left at our house too every year. Well, hopefully not on purpose. Well, one year, Oscar's daughter won a sequined pillow. It was like one of those pillows where like it's red, but then if you swipe up the sequence, then it's something else. It was just a picture of Nicholas Cage that got left behind and we get it out every Christmas now. and they think it's really funny. That's actually a really great Yankee swap gift. I agree.
并涉及一些不当行为，而你专为Softys效力。”对。所以特拉维斯就像是，好吧，他很不情愿地交出了他自己做的记者证。肯气势汹汹地闯了进来，他就像是：听着，你们不能这么做。我禁止你们做这篇报道。内德则在回击。最后，肯就像是，好吧，他要动真格的了。他说：“会计们，你们两家公司都效力。
Nicholas Cage sequin pillow that changes like what it looks like, depending on the direction. Yeah. That's brilliant. All right. Ned calls Nicole Detrick Adam and Adelola into his office. He needs the whole team on this story. Travis tries to come in and join the party, but Ned says, I'm sorry. I'm going to need you to recuse yourself because this story would implicate softies.
你们回瑞士去吧。你们被解雇了。”然后他就像是，德里克，你是做销售的。他把他拉了出去。你现在去卖这些手套吧。然后他让会计们离开，因为他们为两家公司工作。所以基本上，只剩下梅尔、内德和妮可了。
and some wrongdoing, and you work for the softies side exclusively. Yeah. So Travis is like, all right, he reluctantly gives up his self-made press badge. Ken is going to come barreling in, and he's like, listen, you cannot do this. I forbid you to do this story. And Ned is pushing back. And then finally, Ken's like, okay, he's going to play hardball. He's like, accountants, you work for both companies.
肯让巴里负责。然后巴里立刻让他们去写一篇关于《查理的天使》的报道。所以他们就像是，好吧，基本上我们现在只能靠自己了。所以现在肯意识到有一个能证明他有牵连的纸质证据。他在每一封电子邮件上都共同署名了。他太荒谬了。
You're going back to Switzerland. You're out of here. And then he's like, Detrick, you are in sales. he pulls him out. You're going to go sell these hand mitts now. And then he makes the accountants leave because they work for both companies. So basically, it's just down to Mayor, Ned, and Nicole.
我觉得这太搞笑了。整个采访镜头简直绝了，因为他基本上说，伙计们，他对每一封电子邮件都回复，好让这一切看起来像是他出的部分主意。对，这样当事情成功时，他就可以说：我从一开始就在这里了。对。
Ken leaves Barry in charge. And then Barry immediately kind of tells them to go write a story on Charlie's Angels. So they're like, okay, basically we're on our own here. So now Ken is realizing that there is a paper trail that implicates him. He has co-signed every email. He is so ridiculous.
难道你们不认识这样的人吗？认识。在我们的工作中，不是在我们的播客工作中，而是在好莱坞的世界里。是的。每当你想让某个项目启动时，总会有那么一个人，他只是“回复所有人”链条中的一员。对。
It's so funny to me. This whole talking head is brilliant because he basically says, you guys, he responds to every single email so that it can seem like it was partly his idea. Yeah, so that when things succeed, he can be like, I was there all along. Yeah.
他们不做真正的开发，不做真正的制片，什么实质性的工作都不做。他们只是在上面刷存在感。对。他们只是回复所有人，说一些诸如“看起来不错”、“喜欢这个方向”、“大家加油”之类的话。嗯哼。
Don't you know these people? Yes. In our work, not in our podcast work, but in the world of Hollywood. Yes. There's always some person when you're trying to get some project off the ground that's just part of the reply all chain. Yeah.
好主意。然后不知怎么的，他们就成了项目的一部分。那就是肯。肯就是那个“回复所有人”的人。肯就是那个“回复所有人”的人，但他更进一步。他接着把他的“回复所有人”打印了出来。对，因为他想要一个纸质证据来证明他是所有这些不同创意的一部分。但实际上他零创意。
They do no real developing, no real producing, no real anything. They just see-seed on it. Yeah. And they just do the reply all with like, looks good. Loving this direction. Yeah. Way to go, guys. Mm-hmm.
他们根本不做真正的开发，不做真正的制作，不做任何真正的事。他们只是坐享其成。对。他们只是群发邮件回复说，看起来不错。很喜欢这个方向。对。干得好，伙计们。嗯。
Great idea. And then somehow then they're part of the project. that's Ken. That's Ken's the reply all man. Ken's the reply all man, but he goes one step further. He then prints out his reply all. Yeah, because he wants a paper trail to prove that he was part of all of these different ideas. But he actually generated zero ideas.
好主意。然后不知怎么的，他们就成了项目的一部分。那就是肯。肯就是那个喜欢群发回复的人。肯就是那个群发回复的人，但他做得更绝。他甚至把他的群发回复打印出来。对，因为他想要留下纸质记录，证明他参与了所有这些不同的创意。但他实际上根本没有想出任何创意。
So Ken decides he has to get rid of this elaborate paper trail that he's created. So he's going to try to enlist Travis. And they have this really fun back and forth. I really liked how he was like, will you help me get rid of this? And Travis is like, yes, we're going to agree on a location, but then when we get there, we'll go to a second location. And then Ken is like, can we just go to a third location right off the top? They're having this like whole like.
所以肯决定摆脱他费尽心机制造的这些复杂的纸质记录。所以他打算拉拢特拉维斯。他们有一段非常有趣的来回拉扯。我真的很喜欢他当时说，你愿意帮我摆脱这个吗？特拉维斯说，行，我们商量个地点，但等我们到了那儿，再去第二个地点。然后肯就说，我们能直接去第三个地点吗？他们就像这样一直在那儿。
Yeah, let's get to it. And finally they're like, fine, we'll meet in the parking lot in 10 minutes. So Ned is now going to do a bold move, in my opinion. He's going to give mayor and Nicole access to his old. softies email. I think they're trying to dig into this softies email to see if they can find who's responsible for the man mitts. Okay. They're doing some mom detective work here. But he's like, yeah, here's my emails. Go through them. I don't have anything to hide. But what Nicole and Mayer find actually is this, I don't even know what you would call it, Jenna. It's like an inspirational
对，我们开始吧。最后他们决定，好吧，10分钟后在停车场碰头。依我看，内德接下来要采取一个大胆的举动了。他要让市长和妮可访问他以前的“软心”邮箱。我想他们是想深入调查这个“软心”邮箱，看看能不能找到究竟是谁制造了男士手套。好吧。她们在这里做一些侦探妈妈的工作。但他却说，行，这是我的邮箱。你们随便查。我没什么好隐瞒的。但妮可和市长发现的其实是这个，我都不知道该怎么称呼它，珍娜。它就像是一个励志
video where Ned is teaching like the salesman how to sale. Like he's saying things like, you've just got to go figure out what starts your engine. So let me hear your engines. Come on, guys, open up, fellas, boom, boom. And then all these salesmen are going, boom, boom. Yeah, I guess they discover that back in his days as a salesman, Ned was so good that the company asked him to make motivational videos for the rest of the sales team. Yeah. And so he's there and he's got this whole different persona. He's got like flicked back hair. He's just like, boo, boo. Like Gary, Glenn Ross, like you got to sail, sail. The mayor has a string of hilarious comments. She does. She says, you look like you, but like 25% more oily. You look flammable. You look like if Draco Malfoy had a cocaine problem. Yes. And he really gets his feelings hurt,
视频，里面内德在教销售员怎么做销售。比如他说一些这样的话：“你必须去找出是什么让你动力全开。所以让我听听你们的发动机。来吧，伙计们，敞开心扉，兄弟们，轰，轰。”然后所有这些销售员都在那儿喊：“轰，轰。”对，我想他们发现内德当年做销售的时候太厉害了，以至于公司要求他为其他销售团队制作励志视频。对。然后他在那里，展现出了一种完全不同的个人风格。他梳着大背头，就像那样，“布，布。”就像《大亨游戏》里那样，你得去销售，销售。市长有一连串搞笑的评论。确实如此。她说，你看上去像你自己，但油腻了25%。你看上去易燃。你看上去就像德拉科·马尔福吸毒了一样。是的。他的自尊心真的受到了伤害，
but he's trying to act like his feelings aren't hurt. And she's like, okay, look, I'm sorry, I hurt your feelings. And he's like, no, not at I like being ribbed. You look like McCulley Culkin now. And then her look to camera is so funny. I know. She's like, hey. He just made it personal. I know.
但他却在装作自己的自尊心没有受到伤害。然后她说，好吧，听着，对不起，我伤害了你的自尊心。然后他说，不，一点也没。我喜欢开玩笑。你现在看起来像麦考利·卡尔金。然后她对着摄像头的表情太搞笑了。我知道。她就像是，嘿。他刚才把事情搞成针对个人了。我知道。
Well, listen, now we're going to get into the mega cringe part of this episode. Yeah. But before we do, maybe we should take a break just to get our bearings. Because we're going to now watch Asmerelda as the ultimate stage mom. We are back. And before we get into some major stage mom scenes, we thought we would kick it off with our Sam. Our first piece of news comes from Cal F in Deming, Washington, who says the Mount Baker Boys wrestling team defeated Blaine last night, 46 to 40 at the duel at home for Mount Baker. Go Baker.
好了，听着，现在我们要进入这一集中极度尴尬的部分了。对。但在我们开始之前，也许我们应该休息一下，先调整一下状态。因为我们接下来要看埃斯梅拉达扮演终极星妈。我们回来了。在我们进入一些主要的星妈场景之前，我们觉得应该先从我们的山姆开始。我们的第一条消息来自华盛顿州德明的卡尔·F，他说贝克山男子摔跤队昨晚在贝克山的主场决赛中以46比40击败了布莱恩。贝克队加油。
I love it. Julie B from St. Charles, Illinois, wrote in and said, Mrs. Bowler is contemplating her. judgment after impulsively acquiring five baby chicks at Easter time this past year. Turns out she acquired four hens and one rooster. Now she braves the frigid sub-zero temperatures every morning to go take care of her sweet hens that are named Night Raisin Blackberry and Mary Poppins, as well as the grumpy rooster daffodil.
我太喜欢了。伊利诺伊州圣查尔斯的朱莉·B来信说，鲍勒太太在去年复活节一时冲动买下五只小鸡后，正在反思自己的判断。结果她买下了四只母鸡和一只公鸡。现在她每天早晨冒着刺骨的零下低温，去照顾她那些名字叫夜葡萄干、黑莓和玛丽·波平斯的可爱母鸡，还有那只脾气暴躁的公鸡“水仙”。
Everyone is looking forward to stretching their wings in spring. Oh, Julie, I was so charmed by this one. I just acquired three new foster kittens. And I know where you're at, Julie. Yeah. It seems like a good idea. And now you have just kittens coming out of your ears or in your case, chicks. But I would like to compliment Julie's ability to name all of these chickens.
每个人都在期待春天展翅高飞。噢，朱莉，我被这个故事深深迷住了。我刚领养了三只新的寄养小猫。我知道你的处境，朱莉。对。这听起来是个好主意。结果现在你身边到处都是小猫，或者对你来说是小鸡。但我还是要称赞朱莉给所有这些鸡起名字的能力。
And daffodil, what a great name for a rooster. I mean, my gosh. Will you name our kittens, Julie? All right, our last around the town comes from Kendra C. in Clearwater, Florida. Kendra writes, the city of Clearwater erected a 61-foot high rubber ducky, along with her 10-foot-tall baby duck at Coachman Park for the month of January. And I guess, lady, lots of people went and took their photos with it. I'm Googling it. I guess they have this duck festival happening all month.
还有“水仙”，给公鸡起这么棒的名字。我的天啊。朱莉，你愿意给我们的小猫起名字吗？好的，我们最后一条关于镇上的消息来自佛罗里达州清水市的肯德拉·C。肯德拉写道，清水市在一月份的科奇曼公园竖起了一只61英尺高的大橡皮鸭，旁边还有一只10英尺高的鸭宝宝。我想，天哪，很多人都去和它合影了。我在用谷歌搜索。我想他们整个一月都在举办这个鸭子节。
Look how big this duck is. Oh, my gosh. It's enormous. I'll put it in stories. Well, there you go. You guys, that was our around the town. Thank you for everyone who wrote in. Well, now that we've warmed your heart, we're going to put a cringe in your spine by explaining what is happening with Esmeralda.
看看这只鸭子有多大。噢，天哪。它太巨大了。我会把它发到快拍里。好吧，就是这样。各位，那是我们镇上的新闻。谢谢所有写信的朋友。好吧，既然我们已经温暖了你们的心，接下来我们要通过解释埃斯梅拉达身上发生了什么，让你们脊背发凉。
Her son is auditioning for Kidmits. And he's doing great. Yeah. Like he does a good job. He's standing there. He says the script. The casting director says, oh, will you do it again? Gives him a little note.
她的儿子正在为“儿童手套”试镜。而且他表现得很棒。对。比如他表现得很好。他就站在那儿。他念了台词。选角导演说，哦，你能再来一次吗？给了他一个小纸条。
He starts to do it again. And all of a sudden, Esmeralda is going to speak up. And she's like, you know what? Can we, wait, do my rewrites. I did some rewrites. So her son is like, okay, he's going to try to do some rewrites. And then Esmerald is like, no, I'm going to do it. And then she takes over and turns the whole commercial into a commercial just starring the mom.
他开始重来一遍。突然之间，埃斯梅拉达开口了。她说，你知道吗？我们可以，等等，按我的改写来。我做了一些改写。所以她儿子就说，好吧，他打算尝试按一些改写来演。然后埃斯梅拉达就说，不，我来。然后她接管了整个试镜，把整则广告变成了一个由妈妈主演的广告。
Yeah, it's like this freaky Friday moment where she stands in front of the camera and then acts like she's seeing some bright light, like some kind of. of like, I don't know, lightning bolt thing. Her whole body starts to shake. And then she's like, oh my gosh, I am now in my mom's body. I am Mateo. Like, it's so, so awkward. So awkward. Well, you know, there was a scene that was in the extended version that would have
对，这就像是一个辣妈辣妹的时刻，她站在镜头前，然后表现得好像她看到了某种耀眼的光芒，比如某种类似于，我不知道，闪电似的东西。她的整个身体开始颤抖。然后她说，哦，天啊，我现在进入我妈妈的身体了。我是马特奥。这真的太，太尴尬了。太尴尬了。嗯，你知道，在加长版里有一个场景本来应该
happened here where basically Ned and Mayer are going out to investigate the manmits and they find like their lab where they're created. The man mitts lab? its lab. And the sort of scientist, the, you know, engineer lets them in and lets them look around. And you guys, it's really worth it if you can find the extended version on Peacock to watch this. Because what the props department must have had to go through to create this contraption, there's basically like a man mitt on a robotic arm that mimics the wiping emotion, you know, to a mannequin's butt. Okay. But it's like on a, it's like on a, it's.
在这里发生，基本上就是内德和市长出去调查男士手套，然后他们找到了制造手套的实验室。男士手套实验室？手套实验室。那个科学家，也就是工程师放他们进去，让他们四处看看。伙计们，如果你能在孔雀网上找到加长版来看，绝对是非常值得的。因为道具部门为了创造这个装置肯定经历了很多，基本上就是在一个机械臂上有一个男士手套，它模仿擦屁股的动作，你知道的，对着一个人体模特屁股。好吧。但它在一个，它在一个，它在一个
It's on a loop, so it's like robotic arm, swings, wipes, swings, wipes, swings, wipes. So it's just constantly wiping the ass of this mannequin. Okay. They had to build that. Okay. So I can't even believe what went into that. And Matt Sown shared a little bit about it. I want you to hear it.
它在一个循环里，所以就像机械臂，挥舞，擦拭，挥舞，擦拭，挥舞，擦拭。所以它就在那儿不停地擦这个人体模特屁股。好吧。他们得把那个造出来。好吧。所以我简直不敢相信为了这个付出了多少心血。马特·索恩分享了一些相关内容。我想让你们听听。
One of the most entertaining scenes was the one where Ned and Mayer sneak into the laboratory. If you notice the machine that is. counting up the number of wipes a man mitt can do. This was something that Greg Daniels was really focused on and really enjoyed building this prop. It now lives in his office. Jenna, that lives in his office. Greg's office has the front desk reception area from the office. Yes.
其中一个最有趣的场景是内德和市长潜入实验室的那场戏。如果你注意到那个机器，它在计算男士手套能做多少次擦拭。这是格雷格·丹尼尔斯非常关注并且非常喜欢制作的一个道具。它现在放在他的办公室里。珍娜，它就放在他的办公室里。格雷格的办公室里有《办公室》里前台接待区。是的。
Pam's desk. And now it has this mannequin robot wiping machine. That's pretty special. It reminds me a little bit of the prop they had to build on the office when Dwight was making Nate unply, to turn the two ply into one ply. Yeah. Yeah. Well, things are kind of starting to turn here on softies.
帕姆的桌子。现在它还有了这个人体模特机器人擦拭机。这真是太特别了。这让我想起了《办公室》里德怀特让内特把双层纸拆成单层时，他们不得不制作的那个道具。对。对。好吧，在“软心”这里事情开始发生转折了。
The softies employees are starting to get complaints. Kimbo is fielding a complaint call. She tries to dismiss it. She can't believe that people are trying to do it. just credit man mitts, their wonderful product. She gets really mad after this one call, and she throws a manmit at the wall. Matt also shared with us about this gag and how it came about, and I think we should hear it. There's a scene where Kimberly throws the man mitt and it sticks onto the glass wall.
“软心”的员工开始接到投诉。金博正在接听投诉电话。她试图不予理睬。她简直不敢相信人们竟然试图去贬低男士手套这个他们了不起的产品。在这个电话之后她变得非常生气，她把一个男士手套扔向了墙壁。马特还跟我们分享了这个搞笑桥段是怎么来的，我觉得我们应该听听。有一个场景是金伯利把男士手套扔出去，它粘在了玻璃墙上。
We had to do several takes of that, getting the manmit more and more damp, so it would actually stick. But when it happened, it was very funny. and the crew broke up. Here's my question. Why is it damp? That is not explained. I thought the same thing. Why does Kimbo have a really damp
我们拍了好几条才成功，把男士手套弄得越来越湿，这样它才能真正粘住。但当它成功粘上的时候，非常搞笑，剧组人员都笑场了。我的问题是。为什么它是湿的？这没有解释。我也是这么想的。为什么金博手里会有一个非常湿的
wad? Ass wiping mitt. Yeah. At the ready to throw at the wall. That goes unexplained. It is really funny. Do kids still do that thing where they go in the bathroom and then you make toilet paper wet and then you throw it up and make
纸团？擦屁股的手套。对。随时准备扔向墙壁。这没有得到解释。这真的太搞笑了。现在的孩子们还会不会去厕所把卫生纸弄湿，然后把它扔上去让它
it stick to the ceiling. Is that still a thing? Is that like the hijinks of children today or not? Maybe. Yeah, I'm sure it's still happening. I'm sure. I mean, here in a minute, the softies people start throwing the big toilet paper rolls at the truth teller employees. Like they hit Adelola in the back of the head. They hit Oscar. And Oscar gets really ticked off. And he's like, listen. there is an art form to the toilet papering. You don't just throw rolls of toilet paper. There's an art form. That's something I'm curious.
粘在天花板上？这现在还流行吗？这算不算当今孩子们的恶作剧呢？也许吧。对，我相信这种事还在发生。我是说，过一会儿，“软心”的人开始把一大卷一大卷的卫生纸扔向“说实话”的员工。比如他们砸中了阿德洛拉的后脑勺。他们砸中了奥斯卡。然后奥斯卡真的被激怒了。他说，听着，扔卫生纸也是门艺术。你不能随便乱扔卫生纸卷。这门艺术。我很好奇一件事。
Do people still tee-p houses? Do people go and do the toilet paper thing? Lady, I don't think we know anything about the youth today is what I'm gathering. I mean, we did just say we're late to the party. What are their hijinks? Yeah. What are youth hijinks today? I feel like youth hijinks are now...
现在的人还会去别人家房子上缠卫生纸吗？大家还会不会去玩卫生纸的恶作剧？天哪，我猜我们对当下的年轻人一无所知，这就是我的体会。我是说，我们刚才确实说过我们消息闭塞。他们的恶作剧是什么？对。当今年轻人的恶作剧是什么？我觉得现在的年轻人恶作剧都是
tech, tech-related. Like you make funny edits or something. You're not actually T-Ping a house or putting saran wrap on the toilet. Yeah, you're not driving to your friend's house in the night. Right. For shenanigans, you make a video. I think maybe. We don't know.
科技类的，科技相关的。比如你做个搞笑的剪辑什么的。你实际上并不是去别人家房子上缠卫生纸，或者在马桶上缠保鲜膜。对，你不会在大半夜开车去朋友家。对吧。为了搞恶作剧，你拍个视频。我想也许吧。我们不知道。
How will we ever know? We won't. It's okay. We can live with it. All right, well, let's move on. We're going to go to a pond. And that pond is a robo. And in that rowboat are Ken and Travis.
我们怎么才能知道呢？我们不会知道的。没关系。我们可以接受这一点。好吧，那我们继续。我们要去一个池塘。那个池塘里有一艘划艇。那艘划艇上有肯和特拉维斯。
And Ken has got a box of files. And he is going to start putting the files just in the pond. Sinking them. Yes. When he's distracted, though, Travis is going to grab some files and hide them in his jacket, though. We realize Travis is kind of, I guess he's being a saboteur. We got a fan question from Layton R in Folsom, California, who said, hello, ladies, at 16 minutes in 16 seconds, we see Ken and Travis in a boat in a lake. Where was that scene filmed?
而且肯拿了一箱文件。他要把文件直接扔进池塘里。让它们沉下去。是的。不过，当他分心的时候，特拉维斯却抓起一些文件藏在了夹克里。我们意识到特拉维斯有点像，我猜他在当卧底。我们收到了来自加州福尔松的莱顿·R的粉丝提问，他说，嗨，女士们，在第16分钟第16秒，我们看到肯和特拉维斯在湖里的一艘船上。那个场景是在哪里拍摄的？
Layton, you always write in the most thoughtful questions. You really do. We really appreciate it. And guess what? We went straight to Matt Zone to find out the answer, and here's what he had to say. So Layton asked the question about the pond that we shot the rowboat scene in. that's actually a tiny body of water right in the middle of the universal lot. We had to stick with a very specific area to shoot because there are satellite dishes in one direction, there are buildings in another direction, and in a third direction were where the trams go by on the universal tour. So we were threading the needle in this little pond to shoot the scene. the only reason that they let us sink these folders of paper that we had to weigh down to get them to sink was because they're ultimately getting rid of the pond and building stages over them.
莱顿，你总是提出最深思熟虑的问题。你真的是这样。我们真的很感激。你猜怎么着？我们直接去找马特·索恩询问答案，以下是他的说法。所以莱顿问了关于我们拍摄划艇场景那个池塘的问题。那其实是环球影城片场正中间的一小片水域。我们必须在一个非常特定的区域进行拍摄，因为一个方向有卫星天线，另一个方向有建筑，第三个方向是环球影城观光车经过的地方。所以我们在这个小池塘里穿针引线地拍摄了这个场景。他们之所以允许我们把这些纸质文件夹沉下去——我们不得不加重它们的重量才能让它们沉下去——唯一的 原因是因为他们最终要清理掉这个池塘，并在上面修建摄影棚。
So they allowed us to submerge the paper because they're cleaning it all out very soon. I have a question. If you had to get rid of something, files, evidence, a body. How would you get rid of it? Well, have you ever thought about that? I had never thought about it until we were doing some construction and we had some flooding in our backyard. And so you can build a dry well. So when there's a lot of rain here and, you know, we don't get a ton of rain, but then all of a sudden we get like weeks of rain and like the ground can't sustain it.
所以他们允许我们把纸淹没，因为他们很快就要彻底清理这里了。我有个问题。如果你必须处理掉什么东西，文件、证据、一具尸体。你会怎么处理掉它？好吧，你有没有想过这个问题？我从来没想过，直到我们在搞建设，后院发了一次水。所以你可以建一个渗水井。所以当这里下了很多雨的时候，你知道的，我们这儿雨水不是很多，但突然之间我们迎来连续几周的降雨，然后地面承受不住。
So we built this dry well. and for those of you guys that don't know, a dry well is like 10 feet deep, and you put these boulders of all these different sizes kind of stacked in sort of like a non-symmetrical way, and it makes a crevasse. So when the water starts piling in and your backyard is getting flooded with water, it goes into this dry well and naturally trickles down slowly into the ground, and the ground absorbs it, which is great for all of the plants and everything, because a lot of people, when it rains, they have like drains that go to the street.
所以我们建了这个渗水井。对于你们这些不太了解的人来说，渗水井大约有10英尺深，你把这些大小不一的巨石以某种非对称的方式堆叠在一起，它就会形成一个裂缝。所以当水开始堆积，你的后院被水淹没时，它就会流进这个渗水井，然后自然缓慢地渗入地下，地面会吸收它，这对所有的植物和一切都很好，因为很多人下雨时，他们都有通向街道的排水沟。
And then the street goes into the runoff. And the ground doesn't get to recoup all that moisture, right? So we had this dry well built. But when they were building it, it's crazy. It's just an enormous hole in the ground. And I thought like if someone needed to get rid of something, they could put it at the bottom of this drywell. No one's going to find it. Made me think of Tony Soprano.
然后街道的水流进径流里。而地面却无法收回所有的水分，对吧？所以我们建了这个渗水井。但当他们建造它的时候，太疯狂了。那只是地面上的一个巨大的洞。我想，如果有人需要处理掉什么东西，他们可以把它放在这个渗水井的底部。没有人会找到它的。这让我想起了托尼·索普拉诺。
That's what I'm saying. Right? Yeah. I mean, there's nothing in my trial. It's what to go on record. Well. But yeah, they dump all the files into this pond. They do.
我想说的就是这个。对吧？是的。我是说，我的审判里可没有留下任何东西。这是要记录在案的。好吧。不过是的，他们把所有的文件都倒进这个池塘里。他们确实这么做了。
And Ken thinks, well, now, I'm good. He's not good. He's not good. Saboteur, Travis. We'll find out later. Well, I think we should check back in with stage mom, Esmeralda. Oscar is going to notice, Esmeralda kind of being ridiculous.
而且肯觉得，好吧，现在我没事了。他可没没事。他才没没事呢。卧底特拉维斯。我们稍后就会知道了。好吧，我觉得我们应该去看看星妈埃斯梅拉达。奥斯卡注意到埃斯梅拉达有点太荒唐了。
And he tries to comfort her son, Mateo. He's like, do you know what gray rocking is? And the kid's like, no. And he's like, listen, my mom was pretty toxic. She was a narcissist. She loved drama. So whenever she got into one of her moods, I'd make myself as uninteresting as possible,
他试图安慰她的儿子马特奥。他说，你知道什么是“灰色岩石法”吗？那孩子说，不知道。然后他说，听着，我妈相当有毒。她是个自恋狂。她喜欢戏剧化。所以每当她情绪不稳定的时候，我就会让自己变得尽可能毫无存在感，
like a little gray rock. And Oscar's like, maybe I shouldn't have gotten myself involved. But, you know, I just want to give this kid a fighting chance, by the way, my mom was not any of those things. He was just trying to help out Mateo. And then Matteo has a talking head where he's like, that old man is a narcissist if he thinks I'm going to listen to him over my own mom. You know, gray rocking is a real thing?
就像一块小小的灰色岩石。奥斯卡心想，也许我不该卷入其中。但是，你知道的，我只是想给这孩子一个抗争的机会，顺便说一句，我妈可不是那种人。他只是想帮马特奥。然后马特奥有个单人访谈，他说那个老头如果觉得我会听他的而不听我妈的话，他才是自恋狂呢。你知道“灰色岩石法”是真实存在的吗？
No. Yes, it's a real way to handle narcissistic personalities. You become uninteresting? Yeah. I looked this up. In a nutshell, the gray rock technique is a method in which you do not, emotionally respond when being manipulated by someone who is controlling or narcissistic. It's exactly what Oscar says in the episode. Because ultimately, narcissists want your full
没有。是的，这是应对自恋型人格的一种真实方法。你变得索然无味？对。我查过这个。简而言之，“灰色岩石法”是一种方法，当你受到控制欲强或自恋的人操控时，你不做出情感回应。这正是奥斯卡在剧中所说的。因为归根结底，自恋狂想要你全部的
attention. And if you become emotionally detached, they will become disinterested in you and move on. But the minute you engage, that's when they start ramping up and the situation can get emotionally abusive and very manipulative. The article that I read noted, using the gray rock method does not mean ignoring them because if you ignore them that can trigger them too right the goal is when speaking to them use a dull voice keep a neutral look on your face avoid eye contact and respond with just a few words also do not ask them any questions do not encourage them to elaborate do not offer any details about your life just be aloof and eventually they will grow bored
关注。如果你变得情感抽离，他们就会对你失去兴趣并走开。但只要你一搭理他们，他们就会开始变本加厉，情况可能会变得情感虐待和极具操纵性。我读的那篇文章指出，使用“灰色岩石法”并不意味着忽视他们，因为如果你忽视他们，那也会刺激到他们，对吧？目标是跟他们说话时用沉闷的语气，保持面部表情中立，避免眼神接触，并且只用几个词回应。此外，不要问他们任何问题，不要鼓励他们详述，不要提供关于你生活的任何细节，只要冷漠以待，最终他们就会感到无聊，
and they will try to engage someone else. Also, do not reveal that you're doing this method. Oh, yeah. No. It's a real thing, gray rocking. I do find, as you were describing that, like when I encounter someone like that, I do just shut down.
然后他们会试图去搭理别人。另外，不要透露你在使用这种方法。噢，是的。没有。这真是个实招，“灰色岩石法”。我确实发现，正如你刚才所描述的，当我遇到那样的人时，我确实会直接关闭自己。
Like I shut off. Yeah. So maybe I've been gray rocking in those moments. I didn't even realize it. But it's hard because I've been in situations with people like that. and they'll know your buttons and they'll purposely try to push them. Because they want some reaction, any reaction, good or bad.
就像我关闭了电源一样。对吧。所以也许我在那些时刻一直在使用“灰色岩石法”。我甚至都没意识到。但这很难，因为我曾和那样的人处在那种情境中。他们会知道你的痛点，并且会故意去戳它们。因为他们想要某种反应，任何反应，无论是好的还是坏的。
Yeah. Yeah. So it's a hard method to do. Yeah. Well, one of the things that's a runner through this is Ned pushing back on Ken about writing this article and the truth teller. And finally, he gets to his breaking point. He's like, if you don't let me tell this story, I'll quit running the paper.
对。对。所以这是一个很难做到的方法。好吧，贯穿始终的一个情节就是内德反击肯关于写这篇关于“说实话”的文章。最后，他到了崩溃的边缘。他说，如果你不让我讲这个故事，我就不干了。
Mm-hmm. And so he does. And he makes this big speech to the bullpen. And no one really is that interested. Like he just goes, he makes it a real moment where he's like, this is it. I have to quit. And then he hands the reins over to mayor. And without even missing a beat, Adam's like, will you let us know where to forward your last paycheck?
嗯哼。于是他真的不干了。他对办公大楼的人发表了一大通演讲。但其实没人在意。就像他直接去，制造了一个真实的时刻，他说，就是这样。我必须辞职。然后他把大权交给了市长。亚当甚至连一秒都没耽搁，直接说，你能告诉我把你的最后一份薪水寄到哪里吗？
Like it's already blip, you're gone. So now mayor's in charge. Lucky for mayor, a drone is going to fly in to where she is. Very subtle. Who's going to notice this giant drone making a loud noise hovering through. through the bullpen, narrowly getting through the doorway, hanging from it a long string with a paperclip holding some files. No one's going to notice this. Well, they're from Travis. They're the files that he sneaked out of the boat. So now she has her evidence, her hard evidence,
就像这只是个小插曲，你已经走人了。所以现在市长掌权了。幸运的是，一架无人机飞向了她所在的地方。非常微妙。谁会注意到这架发出巨大噪音、悬停在办公大楼上空的巨型无人机呢？它险险穿过门口，上面挂着一根长绳，绳端用回形针夹着一些文件。没有人会注意到这个。好吧，它们是特拉维斯送来的。那是他从船上偷出来的文件。所以现在她有了证据，确凿的证据，
and she's going to go find Ken. He's in the commissary. He's at the counter getting ready to order some food. And mayor taps him on the shoulder. And he lets out this. sound, I think we need to hear it. Try our new Greek bowl. There's always a bowl, isn't there in America? Everything's bowls with you guys. This reaction from him cracked me up. I watched it a few times.
她要去寻找肯。他在餐厅。他在柜台准备点些吃的。市长拍了拍他的肩膀。他发出了这样的声音，我想我们得听听。尝尝我们的新希腊碗。总得有个碗，不是吗在美洲？你们这些人什么都是碗。他这个反应把我逗乐了。我看了好几遍。
It's so crazy. I loved everything about this scene. We got this question from Yasmin and Dallas, who said, I love how Ken screams when mayor taps him on back, I laughed out loud. Did it say Ken screams in the script? And that was his interpretation? hilarious. I texted Chelsea about it. She said it took quite a few takes before she was able to hold it together and make this happen. And I guess it was scripted. It was scripted. I reached out to Matt Sone about it and he said there's actually two jump scares in this script. One at the very beginning
太疯狂了。我喜欢这个场景的一切。我们收到了来自达拉斯的雅斯敏的问题，她说，我喜欢市长拍肯的背时肯的尖叫声，我大笑出声。剧本里写了肯尖叫吗？那是他的即兴发挥吗？太搞笑了。我为此给切尔西发了短信。她说她拍了好几次才忍住没笑场并完成这一幕。我猜那是剧本里写的。那是剧本里写的。我联系了马特·索恩，他说剧本里其实有两个惊吓点。一个在最开始，
and then this one, here's what he had to say. There are actually two scares in the episode. At the beginning, Ned is startled by Mayor when he's in the archive room and he discovers that she's been sleeping there and he gives a scream. And then later on, when Mayor sneaks up and startles Ken, when she ultimately asks him to give Ned his job back, both of those scenes were written by Michael Coleman. He was very excited to get a very specific reaction from the actors, and that all came from him. Okay, so are we learning that Michael Komen likes a jump scare? Is he like a horror movie buff?
然后是这一个，他是这么说的。剧本里其实有两个惊吓点。一开始，内德在档案室时被市长吓了一跳，他发现市长一直在那儿睡觉，然后他尖叫了一声。后来，当市长潜伏过去吓唬肯，最终要求他把内德的工作还给他时，这两个场景都是迈克尔·科曼写的。他非常渴望从演员那里得到非常具体的反应，这一切都源于他。好吧，所以我们了解到迈克尔·科曼喜欢制造突发惊吓？他是个恐怖片迷吗？
I wonder. You love a jump scare. I don't mind a jump scare, like in a scary movie. Sure, I hate them. Like, you know what I hate? I hate when someone at night goes down in the kitchen for a snack, and they open the fridge and then they shut the fridge
我想是的。你很喜欢突发惊吓。我不介意突发惊吓，比如在恐怖电影里。当然，我讨厌它们。比如，你知道我讨厌什么吗？我讨厌晚上有人去厨房找零食，他们打开冰箱，然后他们关上冰箱，
and the person's right there. I hate it. You hate that. I'm just waiting the whole time they're going in the kitchen. I'm like, don't go, don't go, don't go. I'll try you that for it. Someone's in the bathroom.
然后那个人就在旁边。我讨厌这样。你讨厌那个。我一直在等他们去厨房的整个过程。我心想，别去，别去，别去。我会在那儿跟你较劲的。有人在浴室里。
They shut the mirror. And someone's in the mirror behind them. Oh, no. Well, listen, Mare is going to sit Ken down. Yeah. And she's going to say, I have evidence. I know that your fingerprints are all over the prototype for manmits.
他们关上镜子。然后镜子里那人就在他们身后。哦，不。好吧，听着，市长要把肯按坐下。对。她要说，我有证据。我知道你对男士手套的原型负有不可推卸的责任。
You signed off on all of this. Busted. And she's like, here's what I'm going to do. I'm going to forget all this if you let us publish this article and you let Ned come back so that he doesn't look like a wuss. And
你签署了所有这些。人赃并获。然后她说，我要这么做：如果你让我们发表这篇文章，并且让内德回来，这样他就不会看起来像个懦夫，我就把这一切既往不咎。
Ken's like, here's the deal. We're all in this together. We're on the same sinking ship. Because if softies goes down, then the paper is gone. So we have all this back inventory now, these man mitts we can't get rid of, and it's going to hemorrhage the company. So they decide, you know what? They're going to reach out to Ned. He is the salesman
然后肯说，情况是这样的。我们都在一条船上。我们在同一艘沉船上。因为如果“软心”倒闭了，报社也就没了。所以我们现在有所有这些积压的库存，这些我们无法出手的男士手套，这会让公司亏空。所以他们决定，你知道吗？他们要联系内德。他可是销售之神，
of all salesmen, right? Yeah. Boom, boom. They're going to ask him to help save the company. He takes such pride, Net lady. Oh my gosh. I love this series of scenes. So here's what they come up with. They're going to repackage the mitts as like a dish towel. Like kitchen wipes. Yes, kitchen wipes. That you throw in the trash. Ned says they're all purpose, all surface, sturdy, ergonomic kitchen wipes. And he is on fire.
对吧？是的，轰，轰。他们要请求他帮忙拯救公司。内德太以此为傲了，女士。噢，天哪。我喜欢这一系列的场景。所以他们想出了这个主意。他们要把手套重新包装成抹布。就像厨房湿巾。是的，厨房湿巾。你可以直接扔进垃圾桶。内德说它们是全功能、全表面、坚固耐用且符合人体工程学的厨房湿巾。他状态大勇。
He is selling them. They get up to 200,000 in sales. Oh, yeah. They're ringing that gong like crazy. Here's my hot take. What? Should Ned be in sales? Yes, why isn't he?
他在卖力推销。他们的销售额达到了20万。哦，是的。他们疯狂地敲着锣。这是我的热门观点。什么？内德应该去做销售吗？对，他为什么不做？
Lean into what you're good at, Ned. He also seems happier. Yes. His whole disposition changes. Yeah. He's like peppy and spirited. He's smiling for the first time in eight episodes. I think mayor should run the paper and Ned should run sales.
发挥你擅长的呀，内德。他看起来也更开心了。是的。他的整个人精神面貌都变了。对。他充满活力和干劲。八集以来他第一次笑了。我觉得市长应该去管理报社，内德应该去管销售。
Yes, 100%. Yeah. And then they can date and it won't be weird because they're in different departments. Well, we just solved all the problems. I did. Look at us. If you need us, we're right here, guys. What's you got going on?
对，百分之百。对。然后他们可以约会，而且不会觉得奇怪，因为他们在不同的部门。好吧，我们把所有问题都解决了。我解决了。看看我们。如果你们需要我们，我们就在这里，伙计们。你们在搞什么鬼？
Ned's going to finish the episode with the talking head. He says, you know, there are several ways to save a paper from writing an important article to quitting to selling a buttload of rebranded kitchen wipes. Today, it was all three. Well, there you have it, folks. I, for one, now want to see the Fatberg. Sam, I think you're with me. We don't have a lot of time. Right.
内德要在单人访谈中结束这一集了。他说，你知道，拯救一家报社有很多方法，从写一篇重要的文章到辞职，再到销售成堆的重新包装的厨房湿巾。今天，这三样都有了。好吧，各位，你们都看到了。我个人现在很想看看“胖山”。山姆，我想你跟我一样。我们没有太多时间了。对。
It's shrinking. It's shrinking. Well, I want to give a big thank you to a few folks for this one. Thank you to Chelsea Fry. Thank you to Matt Sown. We appreciate your tidbits as always. And thank you for everyone who wrote in questions for this episodes and chit-chats and around the towns. We so appreciate you guys.
它在缩小。它在缩小。好吧，我要对几个人表示衷心的感谢。谢谢切尔西·弗赖。谢谢马特·索恩。一如既往地感谢你们分享的花絮。也谢谢所有给这一集写信提问、聊天以及分享镇上趣闻的朋友们。我们非常感激你们。
And finally, before we go, I want to give a shout out to our Office Ladies YouTube. Because we have gone back to the beginning of the podcast, starting with the pilot. And for the next few weeks, we're going to be releasing highlights. Thanks to the folks at Cartuna. Yes, Cartuna Radio. they're going to be animating our clips because, you know, we don't video the podcast, but they have found a really fun way to show highlights with their animation. Yes, highlights from our very first episode of Office Ladies, where we break down the pilot of the office is up now on our YouTube
最后，在我们离开之前，我要向我们的《办公室女士》YouTube频道喊话。因为我们已经回到了播客的起点，从试播集开始。在接下来的几周里，我们将发布精彩片段。多亏了Cartuna的工作人员。是的，Cartuna广播电台。他们将把我们的片段做成动画，因为，你知道的，我们没有把播客拍成视频，但他们找到了一种非常有趣的方式，通过动画来展示精彩片段。是的，我们《办公室女士》第一集的精彩片段——我们剖析《办公室》试播集的内容——现在已经在我们的YouTube
page. And what's really special about it is we are able to include a bunch of our personal photos from the pilot. They pop up throughout the animation. And I just love it. I love it. I love this new visual way. It's a special treat. Yeah. So go check it out. I'll put a link in our stories, and we hope you guys have such a great week. See you next week. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Matt Beagle. Our audio engineer is Sam Kiefer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubico. Odyssey's executive producer is Leah Reese Dennis. Office Ladies was mixed and mastered by Schultz. Our theme song is Ruppertree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
网页上线了。最特别的是，我们能够在其中加入许多我们在拍摄试播集时的个人照片。它们会在整个动画过程中弹出来。我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。我喜欢这种全新的视觉呈现方式。这是一个特别的惊喜。对。所以快去看看吧。我会把链接放在快拍里，希望大家都有个愉快的一周。下周见。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》是Audyssey呈献的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的资深制作人是马特·比格尔。我们的音频工程师是山姆·基弗，副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。Audyssey的执行制作人是莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯。本期《办公室女士》由舒尔茨混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是里奇·布拉特森的《鲁珀特树》。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可留下评论。